سدود تركيه ايرانيه بنيت قبل سنوات على
هذه المياه تقاسم الجيران الخيرات ودفع
صاحبها الثمن على شاطئ الاهوار الجنوبيه
بالعراق يقف الصيادون يتاملون زوارقهم
المهجوره من جهه وعذوبه المياه من جهه
اخرى لربما يكون الرزق وفيرا يجرفون صيدا
قاتما سمكات صغيره تصلح فقط لعلف
الحيوانات
يستذكرون اياما كانت هذه الارض تفيض
بالمياه العذبه على امتداد النظر
اولا السدود سادين علينا الماي وثانيا
الماء هو نفسي تجاف ماكو ما يقوي واحنا
ناس معاني الحلال نموثه قتل الجوع
اكتفاء ذاتي ووفره في المياه هكذا كان
الحال في الاهوار قبل سنوات حروب وازمات
سياسيه عصفت بالمنطقه فتبدل الحال وصار
السكان هم الخاسر الاكبر وتحول النزوح
بحثا عن مهنه جديده الخيار الاول اعلام
الصياعيد هي اللي تركت وظائف ماكو عمل ما
كان بالنسبه لي لا احصل وظيفه بالنسبه
يعني تفيدني اقدر اسدهن بالنسبه لسؤال
العمل ما يسد يعني
هذه المنطقه كانت محميه طبيعيه ضمن لائحه
التراث العالمي قبل ست سنوات لكن حاله
الجفاف القائم مدفوع بعاصفه كامله من
العوامل المسببه يقول الخبراء ورغم اعلان
الحكومه عن خطط للحد من الجفاف الا ان
تحذيرات كبيره يطلقها المختصون بكارثه
بيئيه قريبه هذه المناطق احيائها بالماء
العذب وهذا شيء ثابت وايضا احيائها بان
تكون محميه على الدوله ان تلتفت بشكل
واقعي والدوله ايضا انا اعتقد انه الدوله
هي مشوار الا بالخارطه
موجات نزوح كبيره يعيشها الاف العراقيين
بحثا عن ارض وفره بالمياه والرزق بعدما
تحولت مستنقعات الاهوار الى بنيه قائمه
مليئه بالزوارق الخشبيه المهجوره والاسماك
الميته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات